BLAKE J. HARRIS:
Where should I stand?
Anywhere in particular?
All right.
Well, thank you very much.
I don't know that it was
the first console war,
but it was the one that
defined my generation, my life,
my childhood, and I
think a lot of yours.
So I thought I would
just talk about how
I got into this project and also
how it has been now developed
into two film projects and
then open it up to questions
that you guys would have.
So writing "Console
Wars" was really--
began with me just wanting
to read "Console Wars."
I was a Nintendo kid
originally, and I desperately
wanted-- I was just
telling Michael
that I desperately wanted
a Super Nintendo because I
love my Nintendo.
It was pretty much
the only thing
that kept my brother and
I friends during this time
period.
And I remember asking my father
for a Super Nintendo in 1991
for Christmas, and
I distinctly recall
him saying he wouldn't buy it
for us because he said Nintendo
would then just come
out with the super duper
Nintendo and a super
super duper Nintendo.
And I guess he was
right in a sense,
but I just thought
he was being cruel
at the time since this was
the only thing we wanted.
But looking back and what
prompted me to write the story
was that he was basically
talking about a business
decision that Nintendo had
made not to make the Super
Nintendo backwardly
compatible with the NES.
And for that reason that
somebody made this decision
thousands of miles
away, we ended up
with the Sega Genesis,
which was somehow
a loophole to my father's logic.
And I became a Sega kid.
And so because I think
Sega Nintendo played
such a large role
in my childhood,
and those of us who are
up in the '80s and '90s,
I wanted to investigate
what was going
on behind the scenes, what was
going on thousands of miles
away in these boardrooms
that led to altering my life
and all these ripples that
changed the video game
industry.
And so my
investigation into this
really began 3
and 1/2 years ago,
my brother gave
me a Sega Genesis
for my birthday, which was
what we had when we were kids
because it was not a
super duper Nintendo.
And as I was playing the
game, I was overwhelmed
by the nostalgia and
memories of how fun it was.
And then after this
barrage of nostalgia,
I thought-- my mind was flooded
with questions about why did I
end up with the Genesis.
Where did Sega even come from?
I knew at the time that
Nintendo was the market leader,
but I never realized that they
were so dynamically successful.
I always imagined that it was
a Coke and Pepsi type of thing
where one had a little
bit more market share,
but I didn't realize at
the time that Nintendo
had over 90% of the market and
then Sega came out of nowhere
and then kind of flamed out.
And so to try to figure out what
happened to Sega, where they
came from, how they were
able to really break through,
I went to the Barnes &
Noble on 86th Street.
It's a nice two-story
Barnes & Noble.
And I was looking for the
video game history section,
and so I was at the
film history section,
right next to the
music history section,
and I couldn't find this
video game history section.
And I went to the woman at
the little question mark
information desk,
and I said, hey,
where's the video
game history section?
And she literally laughed at me.
And she said there's no
such section like that.
And I said all right,
well, how about can
I just have one of the
books on Sega, Nintendo,
or the history of video games?
And not only was there
no history section,
but they didn't even have a
single book in the entire store
on the history of video games,
the business of video games.
All they had were
walk-through guides
to the current video games.
And I just thought
that was very strange.
At the time, I was a bit of
an outsider to the world.
I had played video games
as a ton when I was a kid,
but not too much recently.
But I knew it was
a big industry.
And I knew that it was at
least as big as film and music.
And I thought that was really
surprising that for such
a big industry, such a
fascinating industry,
one that has such a pop cultural
footprint, that there wasn't
a book out there that a
mainstream audience, or even
a very devoted
audience, can buy.
And so I looked on
the internet, and I
found that there were some books
out there, some smaller print
books, some out of
print, but the only one
that really touched
on this topic the way
that I liked to read
books-- my favorite books
are "Disney War," "The
Smartest Guys in the Room,"
books about the behind
the scenes business
dealings and also just sort
of about startup culture.
The only one the
really touched on that
was David Sheff
book "Game Over,"
which talked about the rise
of Nintendo in the 1980s.
And it was really great.
I never realized that
there was this video game
crash, this Atari crash
that people called it,
from 1993, where a
glut of bad games
and competing systems that
didn't work with one another
really led to what
people thought
was the end of the industry.
And in hindsight, thinking that
video games were dead in 1993
seems silly, but I can
understand at the time
because the personal computer
was rising in popularity.
And I think there was a
possibility that that would
have really caught
on, and Nintendo
wouldn't have been around,
and we never really
would have had video games in
the capacity we have now, which
is the extent to what happened
in Europe where Nintendo didn't
get there until a
little bit later.
But anyway, so I was
reading this Nintendo book,
and I was enjoying it.
And it got to 19-- the
book was written in 1992,
and it got to the part where
Sega comes on the scene.
And I thought, all
right, now it's
getting really interesting.
Nintendo now has a competitor.
They have 95% of the market.
I know that that changes
the next few years,
and the book ended.
And it said, with the
promise of multimedia
and this world wide web
in the coming years,
we'll find out what happens.
And I wanted to find
out what happens.
And so I had made a
list of those people
I thought could
help me from Sega.
At the time, I had no writing
credits and no produced
screenplays so
that it was pretty
tough to get in touch with
them, but everything really
changed for me when I got in
touch with Tom Kolinsky, who
was the president of Sega of
America from 1990 to 1996,
which up until that point,
I realized was probably
the interesting
time I felt like.
And everything I was reading,
though limited, it kind of went
from A to C. There was this
rise of Nintendo in the 1980s
and resurrecting the
video game industry,
and then there was somehow
Nintendo had a decline,
and Sony entered the
market, and everything
got very different
and much more modern.
There was this time
period, this point B
where something
happened with Sega.
They somehow give Nintendo
a run for their money
and then somehow disappeared.
And so I got in touch
with Tom, and then that
was really when
things crystallized.
It added a human
face to the story,
and coming at this
as an outsider,
it was really helpful to
see it through his eyes.
I also quickly realized
that Tom Kalinske,
more than any other
adult besides my parents,
was probably most
responsible for my childhood.
Before I asked him
naturally, hey Tom,
what did you do before
you got to Sega?
And he said, well,
after college,
I was at J. Walter
Thompson ad agency.
My job there was to take
existing product lines
and figure out new uses
for them, new branding.
And so they had adult
vitamins, and they
created children's vitamins,
and they licensed them
with the Flintstones.
And they created Flinstone's
chewable vitamins.
And I was like, huh, that was
all I ever wanted as a kid.
And then after that,
he went on to Mattel,
and he joined
right after Barbie.
The Barbie line--
the Barbie doll
had had their first down year.
And the founder and
CEO, Ruth Handler,
said Tom, what do you
think about Barbie?
The analysts are
saying her run is over.
Should we focus on other things?
And he said, no that's the
stupidest thing I ever heard.
Barbie can be
anything to any girl.
She put him in
charge of the line,
and he resurrected that
doll and turned her
into a billion dollar
a year industry
by segmenting the
market and coming up
with various different Barbies,
for various different price
points, like Doctor
Barbie, Space Barbie,
and also working with Ken and
giving him some screen time.
And then after that, he
just had a string of hits
at Mattel, my favorite
being the Popples toy,
which for some reason
I really enjoyed.
And then he was asked to do for
boys what Barbie did for girls,
and he helped develop He-Man
Masters of the Universe.
And then after that he
went to Matchbox cars.
And just hearing hit after
hit, I was just like,
oh my god, I should have been
much more nervous meeting
with this guy.
And prior to
speaking with him, I
knew very little because there
was very little out there.
And I googled him, and
I saw he had a Wikipedia
page that was pretty short.
But that was just
what got me thinking
about how there was all these
great people behind the scenes
that really changed the
video game industry, not just
affecting our lives back
then, but also transforming it
from a series of fad
like childish play things
to big business.
And it shocked me that nobody
had really written about it,
and I decided that I
want to write about it.
And so after speaking
with Tom, my first step
was to just compile my thoughts.
Actually, my greatest
resource was one
that I had made so much fun
of until that point, which
is LinkedIn.
I used to think that it was very
silly and Facebook for work,
but I just typed
in Sega Nintendo,
and I saw thousands
of people who
were there at these companies.
And it was a numbers game,
about 10% responded to me,
and I built up my network.
And I put together
this treatment.
There was about 25
pages that started
to sum up why Sega had been
able to compete with Nintendo
and to get to know the men
and women behind the scenes
at these counsel wars.
And this was the
baseline for what
would become my book proposal.
And while writing about--
particularly about Sega,
and learning about how they were
able to compete with Nintendo
and some of their clever,
creative marketing strategies,
which I liken a lot to
"Moneyball", just a smaller
competitor with 1/10 of
the budget, using creative
means to compete with the
big giant of Nintendo.
I felt like I started to
employ these strategies,
and I noticed that one of the
things that Sega did really
well was to align themselves
with celebrities that
were hip and cool and got
their message out there.
And I thought that
there would be nobody
better to help get the
story of "Console Wars"
out there than Seth Rogen.
And so I asked my agent
if he could send over
my treatment to Seth.
I thought there was
no chance at all
that he would possibly
respond, but he did,
and he really liked it.
And I went out to go
meet with Seth and Evan
in January of 2012.
And we talked about
our experiences.
And Seth and Evan,
they're writing,
directing business partners.
And the best part
about that is that they
were childhood
friends, so everything
we were talking about
resonated with them
and brought back memories, just
as it had been doing for me.
And we ended up deciding that
they would produce the feature
film version based on my book,
which I still had yet to write.
I hadn't even yet to
write up a book proposal.
And so I had a lot of pressure.
And then also, they were going
to produce a documentary.
And so having them in our
corner, and then eventually
having Scott [INAUDIBLE]
in our corner as well,
was really the best compliment
I could have possibly received
beside from the fact
that it was just
really wonderful to have them.
Meanwhile, at that
point, I still
had not been very successful
in the writing world,
and I remember meeting with
Seth and Evan on a Thursday,
and then Monday I was back in
my day job trading commodities.
And I felt like
there is something
wrong with this picture
that is just met my hero,
and here I am back
trading commodities.
But it ended up
working out really
well how much time I had.
I ended up spending three
years researching and writing
this project.
And although at
any point, I would
have loved to have
just left my job
and had this book in stores,
having that extra time really
helped me build relationships
with these people,
specifically in the
case of Nintendo, which
is a very interesting and very
secretive, closed off company.
Having that extra
time was really
useful to try to push
down those barriers
and using whatever leverage
I picked up along the way
to get them to speak with me.
But anyway, the one thing that
I always found surprising,
going back to how
strange it was to me
that there was no video
game history section
and there were so few video
game books, even when I had Seth
and Evan and Scott onboard
doing this feature film
and also doing this documentary,
when the book proposal went
out, it went out
to 24 publishers.
And 21 of them
passed, and the reason
was video game books don't sell.
And I thought that was
very odd because there
had been so few
video game books,
and that was the reason I
wanted to write this book.
But HarperCollins saw
the potential in it
and saw it as that "Moneyball",
accidental billionaire,
social network type of story.
And I sold the book
proposal to them,
and I got to quit my commodity
job and work on this full time.
And I spent all of
2013 writing the book
and also directing
the documentary.
And as I mentioned
earlier, one of the things
I didn't realize at all was
how successful Nintendo was.
I knew that they were
the market leader,
but I didn't realize that
they had 95% of the market
and that they had done
that by really just
controlling everything.
Hearing it mostly from the
Sega prospective at first
caused me to see Nintendo
as the villain of the story,
or at least the Goliath in
this David and Goliath tale.
But a turning point for me
was likening them to Apple
and just seeing their
obsession with having a closed
system, a closed
network, and controlling
every aspect of the experience.
And I could understand why
that rubs people the wrong way,
and I could also understand
why some people would
sympathize with that.
I got to hear about
everything from Sega,
and some of my favorite
stories from there,
in terms of the
"Moneyball" strategies,
was the one that really
hooked me and got
me early on in my first
conversation with Tom
was Nintendo was so
dominant that they accounted
for about 25% of revenues
at retailers in 1989.
In 1989, actually, of the
top 30 toys, 25 of them
were Nintendo or Nintendo
related products.
And they just really had such
a stranglehold on this industry
to the point where the suggested
retail price was not just
a suggestion.
And that led to antitrust
lawsuits in 1991.
But Sega, they had
what they thought
was a superior system, which
was the 16-bit Genesis that
was out before
Nintendo had the Super
Famicom or the 16-bit
Super Nintendo.
And so they went
to Walmart, which
was one of the important
retailers at the time,
and they pitched
the Sega Genesis
to the electronics merchant.
And he thought, this
is a great system.
I could see people enjoying
this and buying this.
And so Tom thought,
all right, great.
We'll give you an order form.
And he said, no.
They did not want to
carry Genesis products
for fear of upsetting Nintendo.
Nintendo was so strict,
and also so reactionary,
that if people ever
changed the price
or if people did things they
didn't enjoy, they would--
shipments would
mysteriously vanish
and they wouldn't get
their full orders.
And so Sega knew that this
is what they were up against,
and they used some sort
of grassroots campaign.
Tom and Shinobu Toyoda,
his right-hand man,
were leaving
Bentonville, Arkansas
after another bad meeting
that went along these lines.
And they were in
the cab, and they
saw that there was a
retail space, a big mall
across the street from Walmart's
headquarters in Bentonville.
And they went inside.
They asked to take
a look at the space.
They ended up buying the
space, and they turned this
into a Genesis store
where people can come in
for free, across the street
from Walmart headquarters,
play Genesis.
They didn't sell the
Genesis, so this way,
everyone that went in
there and liked it, would
go into the flagship Walmart and
say, hey, can I get a Genesis,
and they would be told no.
And eventually, this got
so bad, with not only that,
but they bought every
billboard in town.
They bought seat warmers at the
college football games there,
and eventually the Walmart
electronics merchant
called Tom and said, we
raise the white flag.
My bosses are killing me.
Just please get
rid of that store.
We'll carry the Genesis.
And so it was a
lot of strategies
like that that really
got me into this book
because those are just
universal business stories.
And as I mentioned
earlier, my favorite books
are ones about the tech industry
and about startup culture
and about how
underdogs can compete
with people like Nintendo.
And there's was a lot of
stories I found along the way,
but I'd love to answer questions
that you guys might have.
I think that might be a
better way to discuss this.
Anybody have any questions?
Well, how about,
before we do that,
a show of hands of who
was on team Nintendo
and who was on team
Sega back in the day.
Who here had a Genesis?
And what about a Super Nintendo?
It's evenly split.
And who here got beat up on the
schoolyard fighting this out?
All right, so any questions
that you guys might have?
Hey.
AUDIENCE: So currently
they're having
a bit of trouble
currently against things
like Xbox and PlayStation
3, 4, whatever.
Are you seeing any
parallel now that
is happening between--
that happened between Sega
and Nintendo that is
happening currently
with current consoles.
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Absolutely.
The book came out about a month
ago, and most of the times
that I've been able to
speak with people about it,
they inevitably ask, what do you
think about Nintendo nowadays?
They're a distant
third in the market.
And though the book really
focuses on 1990 to 1996,
from the NES to the Sega
Saturn, Nintendo 64,
you really learn about
Nintendo and the blueprint
of the company and
just their and strategy
And it's not
surprising at all to me
that they're in the position
that they are today.
The last section
of the book, which
is broken into five
sections, is called
the tortoise and the hare.
And I think that Nintendo,
during this time,
really was very much the
tortoise, just not reacting
to Sega for a while, very
much to their detriment.
And then in the
end, particularly
because of Donkey Kong
Country, and because they
stuck with the Super
Nintendo while Sega got more
into hardware and
32X and the Sega CD,
Nintendo ended up winning
with the extension of the life
cycle.
But think about the parable
of the tortoise and the hare.
It's really just a matter
of where the finish line is.
If the finish line
had been in 1993,
you would have said they are
idiotic not to react and not
to change what they were doing.
And I think that's a little
bit of the case right now.
I was at E3 last week,
and Nintendo showcased
a lot of great new games, so
maybe they'll turn it around.
But if the finish line was
right now, they failed.
And that shows their
failure to adapt.
They still make
games for families
and for small children,
and I had an opportunity
to meet with their
current president,
and I asked him about-- one of
the best things Nintendo has,
their greatest assets is
there IP, all those great IPs.
And I said, you guys
make great games.
I have a Wii U. There's no doubt
that Mario Kart 8 is fantastic.
But also I'm 31 years old now.
I grew up with Mario
and Zelda and Kirby.
And as much as you're still
appealing to young kids,
there's also those
of us who grew up
that would maybe like
to see you do more
with the IP that appeals to us.
Maybe TV shows, movies,
things with a little bit
more adult themes that
don't need to be killing
and gory stuff, but I
think Nintendo has really
dropped the ball
in that capacity,
and that's why you see them so
far behind Sony and Microsoft.
And the one thing that I
really saw with Nintendo
throughout this processes
was they were so not
into the marketing of the
games, and they really
focused on product development.
And as consumers, for the most
part, that's a good thing.
But it becomes a
bad thing when I
want to play the Wii with
friends and nobody has it
because Nintendo
doesn't really know
what they're doing with this.
It comes with a
tablet, the Wii U.
I don't really understand why.
I think that in a lot of my
stories about playing consoles,
it was always we,
me and my brother,
and if there was only one tablet
between the two of us, that
would have gone very poorly.
So those are the
marketing decisions
that I think Nintendo
just seems to shrug off
and say, we don't care about
that we as long as we have
good games, that's
really hurt them.
And back then, losing in
the counsel wars, at least
at first, wasn't the
worst thing in the world
because they had a war
chest of money saved up
from their Nintendo success.
And making games at that
time cost about $1 million,
maybe $2 million,
whereas nowadays it
can cost tens of
millions of dollars,
not to mention the hardware.
So falling behind is
not such a simple fixes
as it was back then.
AUDIENCE: So slightly
unfair question
about a different--
"Game Over," again
because I've read that book
but not read your book.
But you brought it up.
So apparently, Nintendo
back in the day
wouldn't let you
lower the price.
I never understood
why Nintendo cared.
Like, I'm Nintendo,
and I sell you
a bunch of video
games for $30 a piece,
and you want to
capitalize yourself
by selling it for $32,
rather than the suggested
price of $40 or $50.
What skin off
Nintendo's back is that?
I never understood
why they cared.
They clearly did care.
Was it just
irrational or did they
have some reason behind it?
BLAKE J. HARRIS: From
the Nintendo mindset,
there was a sense that
they were doing God's work,
but they also thought
that to do that work,
it was to absolutely control
the quantities of things.
In their mind, they saw the
Atari crash, the video game
crash, resulting from not
just a glut of bad products,
but just a glut of too many
products, of too many choices.
And even Mr. Arakawa,
Minoru Arakawa,
their president, when
people would say, oh,
Zelda is doing great in Japan,
why don't we bring it over
here?
He would say, no, I want
only this one game to really
be played by people at one time.
So even in that
situation where it
seemed like what do
you have to lose,
you are not really
cannibalizing yourself here,
you're bring in other
game, they really
wanted to dictate every aspect
of the consumer experience.
And sometimes, it was
to their detriment.
So I understand--
they sued Galoob,
who were the makers
of the Game Genie,
because they felt like that
altered their copyright.
And the Game Genie was
video game steroids
to help you cheat to get the
higher levels and extra lives.
So I understand that
Nintendo believing
that that changed the
integrity of their products.
I can understand them
entering litigation there.
But what I never understood
was they went after Blockbuster
and mom and pop video stores
for renting out their games.
And to me that seemed
like another situation
where, if they wanted the best
experience for their consumers,
having the chance to play
the games before-- Back
then you'd spend $50,
and without the internet,
it was just based on
the back of the box.
That seemed like
why would they be
so vigilant about
trying to control that.
So I wish I had a better
answer for you other than
that they just seemed very
obsessed with controlling
everything and do everything
on their own terms.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
To keep it on
Nintendo, you talked
about how they're a very--
tend to be closed off company
and not like to talk.
Did you find in your
process that it was easier
to talk to maybe former Nintendo
employees rather than people
who are still there and had
been there back in the day?
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Yeah, that's
a really good question, one,
because there's so few
former Nintendo employees.
Sega was based in
Redwood Shores and prior
to that was in
South San Francisco.
And so they really
were in Silicon Valley
or just in the area where
a lot of tech was going on.
And also that
mentality where it was
understandable to go
into and out of a company
and to do something for
a short amount of time
and come out, whereas
Nintendo was really
much more like the traditional
Japanese company where once you
signed up there and decide
you were going to be there,
you were there for
the rest of your life.
So speaking with
people from Nintendo,
I felt like they
were all lifers.
About 25% of the people I wanted
to speak with were still there.
But even the 75% had all
left in the past five years
and were all very
protective of the company.
And I think because the
premise of my project
was Sega Nintendo, that was
like a dreaded word, Sega,
and it just brought
back bad memories.
It was really hard to
speak with them at first,
and that was where
it ended up being
very positive that the
project took three years.
Howard Lincoln was the
senior vice president
of Nintendo of America.
He went on to become
the chairman in 1994
after the president of NCL,
the parent company of Nintendo,
thought that his son-in-law
was doing a bad job
and put Howard in
charge for what
he thought was failure
with the Super Nintendo.
And I contacted Howard
three years ago.
I actually contacted
the secretary,
and she said, sorry,
Howard's busy.
Contacted a few months later.
Sorry, Howard's busy.
I contacted Howard directly
because I figured out
the email structure,
and she said, please
don't contact Howard directly.
And so I kept trying
to contact them
because not only was I just
curious what he would have
to say, but I also thought that
it was unfair as a journalist
to get most of the
story from Sega
even though the story was
becoming more about Sega.
And that was where having a book
sold and having Seth on board
put me in a good spot because
eventually, in early 2013,
I said I know that I'm not
supposed to contact Howard
directly, but there's going
to be two movies and a book.
And Howard, and many others, are
featured a lot in this story.
And up to this point,
it's almost exclusively
from his competitors
prospective.
I think that if he's OK
with that, I'm OK with that.
But he might want to rectify it.
And even in that situation
where his secretary
wrote back and
said, oh OK, I think
we should really get
Howard in on this now.
So they decided like this
seemed like a good idea.
They put me in touch with
GolinHarris, they're ad agency,
and I told them
about my project.
And that was in March of 2013,
it took them 2 and 1/2 months
to get back to me,
and they said I
was approved to
speak with Howard.
And I was really excited, and
I contacted all the people
from Nintendo of
America to let them
know because that was implicit
approval from Nintendo
of America because
Howard is currently
the CEO of the Mariners,
which Nintendo owns.
So they were like,
all right, now,
I feel better about
speaking with you.
I'll speak with you on camera.
And then two days
later, GolinHarris
told me, oh, actually your
status is back to pending,
with no explanation.
And then everyone that I had
told from Nintendo America
thought I was lying to
them when I told them
I had approval from Howard.
And eventually got
to the point where
I was going out there
to film, last year,
six people, not including Howard
Lincoln, Nintendo of America
called all them, reminded them
about their NDA agreements,
did as much as they could to
get them to not speak with me.
But luckily, a few
of them did feel
like not only did they had
built a relationship with me,
but also that like guys if
we don't get in on this,
they're going to railroad us.
We're not going to get to
tell our side of the story.
And that went well, and then
eventually I got a call,
and they said OK you
can speak with Howard.
But I had to-- yeah, so from
my perspective, that is also
indicative of where
Nintendo-- of why
they are where they are today.
Not that I-- I think
that they should
have said three years ago,
OK, this random writer
with no credits, we should make
the time to speak with him.
But it was just that every
step along the process
felt like it was 10 times
harder than it needed to be.
And in the end, all I
was really trying to do
was to tell their story,
and the more information
I had, especially in the
sense that I was writing it
where I wanted it to be as
collaborative as possible
and share the chapters
as I was going,
I felt like it could
only help them.
And I felt like they were
just hurting themselves.
Though I think that, in the
past year, they've-- actually,
the found-- not the founder.
The previous head of
Nintendo who was there
for several decades, Hiroshi
Yamauchi, passed away,
and I think that things
are changing a little bit.
And that was my
experience with Nintendo.
Hey, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so if
you'll forgive me
for geeking up for a second.
BLAKE J. HARRIS:
That's all right.
AUDIENCE: A couple of
related points, something
I find interesting
about Nintendo's history
is both the gimmicks
and all the accessories
and the diversification
of their product lines.
So there's things like the
Virtual Boy in the 3DS.
And the product lines, like I
said, the Game Boy especially,
there's the original,
and there's the pocket,
and there's the
color, and there's
the Advance, and the Advance
SP, and the Advanced Micro,
and the DS and the DSI,
and the 3DS and the 3DS XL,
and all of the crazy
accessories, like the mouse
for the Super Nintendo and
The Super Scope, so many
more things including a huge
list that never made it out
of Japan.
So that's one of things
I find really interesting
about Nintendo's history.
I wonder if you have any
ideas or comments there
or if that factors
into your book at all.
BLAKE J. HARRIS: It does.
Well, two things come to mind.
One is what was always
really interesting to me
in the "Console Wars," these
big great 16-bit machines
metaphorically fighting
against one another.
For Nintendo, what really
helped them sustain,
other than the profits that
they had gained from the '80s,
was the Game Boy.
That was the revenue stream
that always kept them going.
I think the game gear
was at least cooler.
It had color.
I had one.
That was what I thought
made me cool back then.
But the battery
life was terrible.
The games weren't as good.
And that was what
kept Nintendo afloat.
The one thing I always really
respected about Nintendo
with the peripherals,
even including disasters
like Virtual Boy, they never
let that-- I guess just
because they weren't so heavily
emphasized on the marketing,
they never really let that
change their narrative.
They were there to give
you the console experience,
and if you wanted, you would
get these other things,
whereas I think Sega
did a little bit more
of throwing them in
your face and trying
to make them much
more aspirational.
And particularly in the case
of the Virtual Boy, which
I think most people would
agree was a terrible product
or at least not one they really
should have put both feet into,
the people that I spoke with
from Nintendo of America said,
we knew we had a dog.
And they were pretty blunt
about that with the retailers.
So it did come out and
there were commercials,
but they didn't really
throw it out there
and put a lot of money
behind it the same way that's
Saga did with the 32X, which
was another product that people
didn't really enjoy and
felt like created baggage
and was showed distrust between
Sega and their consumers.
So I think it speaks to
Nintendo always trying
to innovate even
though they can be
a little stiff and rigid in
certain areas of the company.
They also had a
knitting machine.
They're willing to try things,
and that is pretty impressive.
The one other thing I liked,
that is not in the book,
was they did a online
lottery in Minnesota in 1991.
And so they were
willing to try things.
But I think in the
end, Nintendo has
built a trust with
their consumers
that they're not
going to really push
for things that
aren't worth buying,
and I think that counts for
a lot for a company that's
been around as long as
they have and has done
the same sort of
thing over and over.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So how
much of the structure
of the console
industry today do you
think was shaped by console
wars between Nintendo and Sega.
So like things like, when we
think about the four to seven
year of the console life cycle
and first party versus third
party games and subsidized or
at least break even hardware,
is that all stuff that is
inevitable or is that defined
in this era ?
BLAKE J. HARRIS: I mean,
personally, I think a lot of it
was defined in this era.
Since we don't have the
experiment of not having
the war, we don't
really know for sure.
But the most important
thing, I think,
that also seems like
a no duh in hindsight,
is just that there was two
competitors in the market,
and they were both
very profitable.
Up until that point, I think
Atari have been very profitable
in the '70s, and then
Mattel and Coleco came along
and that ruined the
balance of power
and led to the industry, at
least from one perspective,
to spiral out of control.
And there was a sense that the
console industry could really
only sustain one
company, and maybe it
would be Sega,
Nintendo would fail,
but the fact that both of
them were able to succeed,
and then even Sony came into
the ring and also found success.
I think that alone is
pretty pivotal in terms
of giving the
confidence eventually
for Sony and Microsoft to
enter and for both of them
to be successful.
And then one thing
that even speaks
to what Nintendo does today is
they are focused on children
and that family friendly
type of product.
Back then, the games-- I
remember buying most of them
at Toys R Us and KB Toys, and
it was really a toy product.
And I think that what Sega
did, which was primarily
from financial necessity at
first in terms of just zigging
wherever Nintendo
zagged, they went
after adults and teens and
a different demographic,
and they turned it more
into consumer electronic
and into a bigger business.
And so I think there was a
big tectonic shift of what
console business could be
through what Sega was doing
through-- who they
were advertising to.
I learned you just see
throughout the book there's
a lot of innovations just
in terms of the first street
date for a video game.
Nowadays, that
seems commonplace,
but back then it was like
we'll get it to these retailers
whenever we get it to them,
then we'll get it to these guys.
And not only was that a
problem for just not being
able to look forward
to like oh this game
comes out on September 17,
but Sega did such a great job
of Hollywoodizing the
industry and building up
the months of hype
leading up to that date.
So I think there was a lot of
changes during that period,
mostly from the marketing
standpoint of Sega
and then also just from
the infrastructure.
One of the climaxes of the
book is the Senate subcommittee
hearing in December of 1993,
where Joseph Lieberman brought
Sega Nintendo down
to Washington to talk
about how violent these
games were becoming,
which maybe looking back
don't seem that violent.
But it was Mortal Kombat and a
game called Night Trap, which
was a terrible game
that was actually
invented seven years earlier.
And it was just silly to
me that it was involved.
But the resolution to
these subcommittee hearings
was that Sega Nintendo had
to put down their swords
and work together.
The only way that
they would get out
of the government taking control
and regulating the industry
and basically just controlling
what went in and out
and hurting both these
companies in the long run
was to get them to sit
at a table together,
and it was fun in the
book to actually write
about that meeting where
they had to sit at the table
together.
And they just hated any idea
that the other one came up with
just for the sake
of-- in the end,
they came up with a rating
system that was almost
identical to Sega's
rating system,
but Nintendo wouldn't have
adopted that right away
because it was Sega's.
So they had to work together.
And so long story short,
what they came up with
was the ESRB, the
Ratings Board, they also
came up with the
trade association,
which puts on the E3
trade show each year
for the video game industry.
Up until that point, all
of the big presentations
and the big news and the only
time that actually the Sega
Nintendo people would interact
in person was at the consumer
electronic shows in
Chicago and Vegas.
And now they had their own show.
And as much as my book is
the story of these characters
these pioneers as much
as it is about Sega
and how they're able to use
these underdog strategies,
it really is just about the
maturation industry during that
five year stretch to go from
Nintendo controlling it all
and selling their toys-- selling
their games in toy stores,
to having the first
E3 show and having
that we've arrived moment.
AUDIENCE: So I seem to remember
hearing a story about how,
at one point, Nintendo
basically had the opportunity
to buy like what became the
PlayStation at some point,
and I wonder if you had
any just comments on that
from your research.
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Sure.
So there was a point
when I was writing
the book-- I'd say early
on my biggest inspirations
were "Moneyball" and
Ben Mezrich's Accidental
Billionaires.
But I was speaking with a
guy named Olaf Olafsson, who
was at Sony during
that time period,
and he has probably
the coolest name ever,
but he also was in charge of
Sony publishing entertainment,
which back then, Sony
was a third party.
They made games mostly through
their company ImageSoft
that were for Nintendo.
And I was asking him
about sort of seeing it
from that perspective
before eventually creating
the PlayStation
and launching that.
And he said to me,
very explicitly,
I met with Howard Lincoln and
the other guys at Nintendo,
and they treated us like
slaves on a plantation.
I was like, wow, that's
pretty charged language there.
Are you sure?
He's like, yeah,
it was terrible.
They dictated their terms.
They treated us like slaves.
And so those two business
books I had mentioned
had been my inspiration
up that point,
and I felt like after
that meeting with Olaf,
I started really seeing
this as Game of Thrones,
that it was these
rival companies,
each feeling like
they were destined
to rise to the top or at
least deserve certain things
or were being slighted
in certain ways.
And so in the
particular case of Sony,
their story which lurks
throughout this narrative
and is like the third party
that you don't even realize
is going to be entering
the race, is in a-- 1991
at the summer consumer
electronics show,
Sony and Nintendo were
supposed to announce
that they had-- that
Sony had made a CD
attachment for
the Super Nintendo
that would be like the
equivalent of the Sega CD
but for the Nintendo.
And on May 31, 1991, Olaf
made a presentation that
was not heavily
attended because Sony
was a small player
at the time and said,
I'm pleased to announce
that Nintendo and Sony will
be making this device.
And then the next day, Nintendo
had their presentation.
And this was much
more heavily attended,
and Howard Lincoln said,
we're pleased to announce
that we're doing
a CD attachment.
And Olaf was like, yeah.
And then he said that it's
going to be with Philips.
And so they very
publicly slighted Sony.
That also speaks
to a lot of what
Nintendo did during this time.
It's not always-- most of life
I don't think is what you say,
but how you say it.
And they didn't always have
the best bedside manner,
or they at least wanted
to put their foot down
when they could.
And so they went out of
their way to embarrass Sony
and not work with Sony
during that time period
to have what would've been
the Nintendo PlayStation
or some early iteration of that.
And what I always loved about
Sega was everything about them,
in those early years, was just
a lemons to lemonade strategy.
And Tom Kalinske saw
that and thought,
all right, well I
hate Nintendo too.
Let's talk.
And so they met-- Tom
met with Olaf Olafsson,
and they developed a
close relationship.
And they ended up-- they were
releasing their own Sega CD
system, and they did not have
the necessary software, just
in terms of quantity
to get it out there,
and they said to Sony, you guys
are having a lot of trouble,
Nintendo not
approving your titles,
not letting you make
as many as you want,
which is not giving
you the opportunity
to recoup your investment.
Why don't you make as many games
as you want for the Sega CD?
We'll be partners in this.
We'll even have our guys
teach you how to make games
because one thing that I didn't
realize really early on or it
just didn't occur to me was
Sega Nintendo did have a lineage
in the arcade market whereas
Sony didn't, and Microsoft,
too, didn't.
So they're even more outsiders
into the console world.
And so Sega and Sony
worked closely together.
They actually--
when Sega officially
launched the Sega CD, they
had a press conference
in New York and Olaf
was there by their side,
like it was very much
almost like a joint venture.
And from that
point, that had gone
so well that Sega
of America and Tom
wanted to create the next
generation console together
and continue to team
up against Nintendo.
And they had produced--
for six months,
Sega and Sony worked
in conjunction
to make what would have
been the Sega PlayStation.
And something that I
think we have done better
than the Sega Saturn, but Tom
brought this to Sega Japan,
and they rejected the idea, and
they broke up the partnership.
And that was what was really
fun for me with this project.
Going in, I assumed that the
battle between Sega Nintendo--
that the most interesting story
the most interesting conflict
in the book would
be Sega Nintendo.
But it turned out to
really be Sega of America
and Sega Japan and these
cultural differences
that really, I think, resulted
in the failure of the company.
As much as we all
think Sega Nintendo
and it brings us back
to a certain time
or it at least reminds
us of a corporate battle,
that was not the case in Japan.
Over here, Sega did go from 5%
of the market to 55% or 60%.
In Japan, they never
really had more than 15%
or 20% on the market.
So they had the same exact
products, the same exact games,
but over there they
were not successful
and over here they were.
And that created enormous
friction between America
and Japan, not just of
the cultural confusion
of that nature, but these were
the people-- for the most part,
they were making
all the hardware,
and they're making the
majority of the software,
and they were watching
their subsidiary succeed.
And they're dictatorial
leader Hayao Nakayama who's
known to walk around with a
golf club and whack things
and was a very
intimidating force,
would say to them, why are
you guys not as successful
as they are in America?
And those a lot of reasons why.
I think some of it is just
their risk appetite, which
was much more limited
than those in America.
But another thing is the
laws against monopolies
and monopolistic
practices in Japan
are much easier than
they are over here,
and Nintendo had much
more stranglehold.
But the book
presents that dynamic
and says that as a result of
that conflict, that civil war,
going on during this
console war, that's
the reason that Sony ended
up going on their own,
and Sega ended up with a
failed hardware system.
And I guess Sony is laughing all
the way to the bank in the end.
And it was sad to
read all about that.
And for me, because of
this conflict with Japan
and because things didn't
end up rosy for Sega,
hearing that from Tom Kalinske
and Al Nilson, and all
the other employees, I was at
first immediately a little bit
skeptical about the role that
Japan had played at Sega.
I thought you know
there's a little bit
of revisionist history
or them blaming
all the failures on Japan
and taking credit for all
the successes, and that's
possibly true to some extent.
But in the middle
of the project,
I got hired by
Sega to go to Japan
and shoot some short
documentaries for them.
And I was hired
by Sega of America
to go interview developers
from Sega Japan,
and I saw firsthand
that, to this day,
the conflict between
both sides is terrible.
Everything that Sega of America
asked for, Sega of Japan
wouldn't give them.
And it was always done in
a passive aggressive way.
And it was sad, and I guess that
also lent a lot of credibility
to me for what I
was hearing even
though it was 20 years later.
AUDIENCE: So I think in the
modern era of video games,
a lot of developers gain
a lot of prominence.
And they become super
celebrities in their own right.
I just had-- I haven't
read the full book yet,
but I was wondering if you'd--
if it was that also true back
then.
Were there like super
star developers?
Obviously, the whole
game media industry
wasn't as developed
so maybe they
weren't as prominent
in the game development
environment or culture.
But were they there?
Were there like a few
superstar developers
that were doing that?
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Yeah.
No, that's a good question
AUDIENCE: Also, how did Sega
court them if they were there?
How did they get them
to join the dark side?
BLAKE J. HARRIS:
There were maybe,
within the company, the
superstar developers.
But even when those
internally were aware,
they weren't treated as such.
They were treated just
like any other employee.
I mean particularly Shigeru
Miyamoto at Nintendo
and Yuji Naka at Sega, both
responsible for Mario and Sonic
respectively and a
bunch of other games,
were like the golden
geese at each company.
They were popping out
these great titles,
but they were not
treated very well there.
They did not, even early on,
get their names in the credits.
And actually, one
thing I never realized
was that after Sonic one--
after the first Sonic
game came out and was enormously
successful, Yuji Naka,
because he was upset
about the lack of credit
and the lack of respect
that he and his team
had gotten-- they
weren't even allowed
to put their names in the
credits-- that they quit,
or he quit Sega.
And it took Shinobu Toyoda,
from Sega of America,
going over there and bringing
him to Sega of America
where he worked at what they
called the Sega Technical
Institute, which was supposed
to be a fusion of East and West.
And they actually made
Sonic 2 in America.
And I felt like, in terms of
this cultural conflict, that
was the high-point
for this relationship.
That was my favorite
game back then,
and I think also
showed what was best
for both sides of the company.
But it wasn't really
until, I think, Sony
entered the picture, and until
games became a little bit more
sophisticated and
CD-based that developers
got the respect
that they were due
and were treated like the
rock stars that they were.
I mean my book,
for the most part,
focuses on the business
side and the executive side.
And they deserve all
the credit in the world,
but, at the end of the day,
what they were selling,
the underlying products, were
being made by these developers.
They were the ones creating
the content, creating the IPs.
And I think historically they
haven't been treated very well.
And even nowadays, at those
big companies, particularly
the Japanese companies, I still
think that they don't really
get the respect they're due.
AUDIENCE: Sega and
Sony are really--
I mean Sega and Nintendo are
really friendly right now.
Sonics and Smash Brothers
and the winter Olympics game,
is that weird for
people working there?
Like, are they upset?
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Yeah.
I mean for me, I remember
my seven-year-old cousin
I was telling about the
project I was working on.
I said, do you know Sonic?
And he said, oh yeah,
he's friends with Mario.
And I was like no,
he hates Mario!
So it's weird for me.
But also, one of the best-- one
of the most fun parts for me,
as a writer and filmmaker
throughout all of this,
is that speaking with
people from Sega Nintendo,
they still hate the other one.
It wasn't like-- I initially
pitched it as a Magic Johnson
and Larry Bird, like two
tough competitors that
pushed each other
to another level,
but put their arms
around each other
at the end, that was
not the case here.
Because they both dislike
one another so much
and still don't have
any kind things to say,
they hate the idea.
It's blasphemous that Sonic
and Mario would be together.
I hate seeing it though I guess
it makes sense because Nintendo
really has planted a flag in
what Sega used to paint them
to be, which was that they were
the uncool company or at least
the one that was focused
on kid friendly products.
And Sonic really still is
that kid friendly product
the my seven-year-old cousin
would know, so it's weird to me
that they work together,
But I think it actually
makes a lot of sense
from a business
standpoint at this point.
HOST: All right.
Let's just give Blake a great
round of applause for coming.
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Thank you.
HOST: And there are
copies of his book
available from
McNally Booksellers
at a subsidized
price so if you're
interested in that please
go and purchase them I'm
sure Blake would be happy to
field any individual questions.
BLAKE J. HARRIS: Yeah, I'm
happy to sign any books
or I'm happy to
answer any questions.
I really do love this topic, not
just because I grew up with it,
but I found it so fascinating.
I felt like even if this is
about rival tissue companies,
it would have been
90% as interesting.
And I still continue to
do interviews and speak
with people and try to learn
more, even though at this point
I mean maybe it'll be
in the paperback version
or maybe it'll be
in something else,
but I just find it
personally interesting.
So feel free to ask me anything.
I love talking about it.
Thanks so much guys.
I really appreciate it.